[Musique]
aurélie doit faire une course dernière
minute à l'épicerie il ya beaucoup de
neige dans le stationnement et aucun
espace disponible pour garer sa voiture
elle trouve une place dans le
stationnement du commerce voisin
à son retour quelques minutes plus tard
sa voiture a disparu
un remorqueur stationné un peu plus loin
lui fait singh aurélie lui demande où il
a déplacé sa voiture le remorqueur et
6,65 dollars en argent comptant avant de
lui donner la réponse
le remorqueur est il dans son droit non
légalement il n'a pas le droit de
retenir le véhicule pour exiger de se
faire payer
pourquoi parce qu aurélie n'a conclu
aucune entente contrat avec le
remorqueur dans ces circonstances
retenir le véhicule est considéré comme
de l'intimidation
aurélie peut donc exiger que le
remorqueur lui révèle où il a déplacé sa
voiture tout ce que peut faire le
remorqueur c'est tenter d'obtenir
l'adresse d'aurélie pour lui faire
parvenir une facture le fin mot de
l'histoire
ne soyez pas à la remorque de ceux qui
veulent vous intimider